hey everybody its Jessie sorry I did not
get the tweet out about this video until
3 minutes ago so I don't know if how
many people rely on Twitter to know when
I'm gonna go live so maybe it'll be a
little bit slower here at the beginning
in terms of viewers also I didn't even
get the event scheduled until maybe
about an hour ago
so today's just been I got in late and I
had all kind of stuff going on
I actually just interviewed a student
who's interested in working with my
department so that would be awesome if
it works out I know he has another
interview with a company near here as
well so I wish him luck with that but
hopefully he decides to work with us so
yeah I'm just going to wait I'm not
going to get started for maybe a couple
minutes we'll just talk for a little bit
just to wait for some people to come in
because I am I learned this so late
there we go okay now what now we're at a
normal it was showing seven viewers for
a while and now it just jumped to 54 so
that's closer to our normal amount of
viewers all right I guess um yeah we got
some people looks like some new new
faces new names in the live chat um the
heaven I don't remember seeing before so
hey everybody we got a hello from the
Ukraine awesome and let's see la tell me
if I pronounce this wrong is it laQuita
or lakita let me know how if I
pronounced that right but on time for
lives head so awesome
and Yusef asked will you do a to do lap
with react from scratch
okay now we're picking up we're up over
70 viewers now so let's uh let's get
started all right everybody shout out
where they're from we got India
Barcelona UK awesome thanks for watching
from from Chile from Rome
awesome wow we have people from all over
so it looks like yeah it looks like
we're getting some retweets here so
that's picking up picking up fast from
Los Angeles Romania alright so today I'm
really excited about this topic and this
was totally I hadn't planned on doing
this today but I got a pull request from
well I actually got two pool requests so
let me let me bring these over just to
show you because I want to give give
credit where it is due
so between yesterday's show and today's
show I got to pull requests this one is
from Dani and you can check that I'm not
going to go through all these on the air
because you can see in the link in the
show description you can check these out
but had some cool stuff here kind of
preparing for even more so I'm expecting
I guess another another pull request
here but did some kind of some
optimization things so not no changes
that would really be visible like to the
user but definitely going to make things
more readable easier to maintain in
terms of the code the other pull request
this is what we're going to be talking
about today
so Vinay this is the second pull request
he had a great one I think it was a few
days ago or maybe yeah I think it was
Friday that we talked about yesterday
but this one so if you were here
yesterday for the live chat there was
some talk about using
winters and things to try to get more of
a standard style to the coding so I I
haven't I've been a little bit sloppy
encoding this and in general I've been
sloppy for two reasons one the timeline
for this was really tight so I just kind
of cut corners in terms of formatting
everything properly to get it launched
also it's it's always been just me
working on projects and that's allowed
me to get a little bit lazy because
nobody's ever around to call me out on
it and I'm not saying that that's a good
thing that's definitely not a good thing
but that's just how it happened but now
it makes a lot more sense for me to have
kind of a standard format for my code
because all of you are looking at the
code and you're helping me we're
collaborating on this so great idea so
we're going to use I don't know if you
can hear that but my stomach is growling
so if you hear that I'm sorry sorry but
I just I forgot to eat today so I don't
know if that happens to you but
sometimes you just get you get working
and you know before you know it you
haven't eaten so I'll have to make sure
I eat after this dream so we're going to
use a couple of things and you've
probably been seeing some of these
things I know at least I've been seeing
them on Twitter a lot mentioned prettier
and standard j/s I'm going to kind of
take you through what I did I know it
looks like I haven't merged these yet
but I did merge them I just haven't
pushed it back up to to github but let
me bring over to thing I'm gonna bring
over my command line and I'm also going
to bring over or I'm going to show you
the code I've linked in the show notes
to standard J s their website and to the
website for prettier so you can check
that out you know kind of as we're going
if you want to learn more about it and
first of all let me show you I do I want
to show you the amount of errors that I
had once I finally ran this up so let me
go
back up so this is kind of I like slowly
just narrow down the errors I think this
is the first set so at first I had all
these errors of just things a lot of
them was components that I had imported
or into another component and then I
never used it so I had I guess at some
point thought I was going to use it and
then never removed it I was really
surprised at how many of those there
were because I I thought that I was
usually pretty careful about that but
evidently I was not so those are a bunch
of bunch of stuff there also if you
remember from our episode whenever we we
were making jQuery work with react and
we had a bunch of functions in a
separate file in our in our whatever
file was at our app dodged a as file
yeah so we had in a separate file
we had these functions that were using
jQuery but then we are calling them in
component did mount so to when we're
using standard JSU's --is es Lent kind
of behind the scenes it was looking at
that component and saying you're trying
to call this function and it's not
defined it really it was defined in our
other other document and then not only
that but it was looking at that document
where we actually had to find those
functions and saying hey you defined
this and you never used it so so most of
the areas I had were because of that
okay so not really a big deal so I'll
show you how I fix those errors because
I'm guessing that maybe if you're going
to try to use this for the first time
you might run into some of these errors
as well I mean maybe hopefully you're
not as as bad as I was with with my code
and you don't get as many errors but
I'll show you how to go over those how
to fix those errors I'm going to show
you my package.json first so that if you
if you want to try this out but you
don't really want to like pull down my
code you can just kind of piece it
together
so let's move this off before I show you
how I did those and we'll go to my
package.json let me know if this is this
is too small
I'll just I could probably let me make
it a little bit bigger right now
I don't want to make it too big because
I want you be able to see kind of like
the big picture here of what we what we
have now that we didn't have before and
I have some things up here that are new
too but they don't really apply to what
we're talking about today so basically
we have this whole section now that's
dev dependencies and this this is what
has been brought in okay and remember
this is all from Vinay's pool requests
almost none of this is stuff that I did
the only thing in here that I did on my
own was I I imported this babble es lint
package and I'll explain why I needed
that in a minute
so basically these these four things got
this working and then we have some new
commands so we have this lint all right
we have pre commit and then we have lint
LED stage all right so we have a lot of
things going here basically even a set
this up which is very very nice of him
he set all this up to look through all
my folders where I had components and
JavaScript files and to go through lint
those and then automatically reformat
them based on the standard jazz
specifications so that's what the the
linting art is more like the standard
jazz the reformatting is from prettier
okay and if you check out the docs for
those you'll see so this is what's added
also I I added this part down here and
this was basically to deal with some of
the errors so I'll talk about that in a
second when I deal with those errors and
that's it and as soon as I'm going to
push this code I might as well do it
right now let me push this to get up
right now so you can follow along and
everything is is up-to-date
on my other screen I'm just making this
a figure you you all know how to run a
commit but also you see this is new so
this is basically this is happening
right when we run a commit before we
were just going to commit now all of
this runs before the commit happens so
really you can't you can't make a commit
now without everything being put in a
standard format which is awesome and
that was that was from Vinay that's what
his additions here are doing all right
so all this is now being pushed to the
master branch and it's completed so if
you go to the repo on the master branch
you can see all of this you can open up
the package.json you can see everything
I'm talking about follow along so let me
talk about some of these errors I'm not
going to go over every single error just
the ones that I think were kind of like
it was kind of tricky for me to figure
out and kind of like to share how to get
around those so let's see we had these
ones as I said are really easy I just
define these components and having to
use them okay so some of these like I
said I've been defining these functions
and not actually using them well I was
defining them in the app DOJ's file but
not using them there and then I was
using them in components but it was
coming up is not defined so here's how I
got around that so for some of them like
for fetch and for you know the dollar
sign I just added them globally as since
I basically I use fetch and almost all
the page-level components so if you just
add this you know this this whole
section here
okay including the ending things that
fix that so basically that just lets es
lint know that it's okay you can use
these they're defined somewhere and it's
alright to use so that fix those errors
but then you don't want to do this for
for everything let's say you only use
something once you don't to make it a
global so at the page level I did
something like this so I use in
component did amount I use and knit tabs
okay this is like I said this is defined
over here in app J s so what I did here
is I just added at the top in the
comment global and then the name of this
function okay and that got rid of that
error and I did a similar thing in every
component I just put the name of the
function so that got rid of those errors
you know no big deal
in reality at some point if I have more
time now I know I've discussed this
already with with all of you that this
project needs to wind up so there's some
things that I know should be done that
may not get done because they're not
essential to the project functioning and
I need to move on because I have a lot
of other projects that are lining up
that I need to start working on so we'll
see maybe if I get some of these student
workers that might be a good thing a
good project for them to come in and and
do some of this but I figure you know
there's definitely a better way to do
this than to have all this going in a
you know separate file so that may
happen at some point
now the next the next error that I do
want to talk about that was the
trickiest was this one so in resources J
s which is the file were and now it said
there's a parsing error unexpected token
equals on line in this case it was line
11 which this is probably different now
since I had changed it so the line it is
now the 12 so it was basically throwing
an error because we did this
so the way that I found to get around
this is basically it wasn't it wasn't
recognizing that like we're using this
class here okay so it had something to
do with that all right I'm not claiming
that I know technically everything that
was going on but basically the problem
was that this is a newer syntax and it
needed to recognize that as a near
syntax so that's why I installed this
babble es lint okay if you're not
familiar with babble that's a transpiler
that lets you use the latest JavaScript
syntax and it turns it into older syntax
that older browsers can handle okay so I
am imported this so just yarn add babble
es lint and then I added the flag -
capital D okay where you could do - -
dev either way it will put in your dev
dependencies that added here and then
down here you can add you can say what
parser you want
yes lint to use so I added this to the
parser so I'm saying es lint but just
recognize that it's standard that's
doing this but it's using es lint kind
of in the background okay so we are
talking about standard J s alright so
that's it that's the only the only
things I really had to do I guess I'll
show you the app J s just in case
hopefully this won't be an issue with
you because you won't have all these
functions sitting in a separate file
like this but all I did was all these
functions are the one that I'm using in
components and I'm not using on in this
particular file so at the top I just did
es lint disabled and then at some point
down here I Rhian able yes lint so I
enable it again here so the disadvantage
is like everything in here is not
getting elected properly although I did
run lint before I did this so all the
other errors that were in here I fixed
so these are all okay because
I did it before hand so I could you can
actually like specifically put in like
the one rule that you want to rule out
inside here but I couldn't find what it
was I tried a couple of different ones
and it wasn't working so just for the
sake of getting this working before the
video I I just disabled everything
within here okay
so that's pretty much it that's all it
took
I mean on my end that's all it took to
get this working Vinay I'm sure had had
more work on his end and you can check
out his his pull request to see all the
work that he did and everything that
changed all the files have changed but
at this point let me show you the
results I know I've been ignoring the
live chat for a few minutes I will get
to you know answer the questions just a
minute but I wanted to I wanted to try
getting to the point quickly and getting
through it how because usually what
happens is I get a bunch of viewers
right off the bat and then we kind of
like I kind of mess around a little bit
and just kind of talk about some general
things before we get started and I
usually lose a bunch of people probably
because this may be their first time
viewing and they're thinking like what's
this guy doing I thought he was going to
talk about whatever I the title of the
video is so that's why I'm ignoring the
lab chat right now but I'll get to it in
a minute I just want to give you an
example of how everything is it's now
formatted kind of Auto formatted and
let's see let's try to do a side-by-side
so I'm going to bring up this code and
you can do that you can open this up and
get up as well on my other screen I'm
just opening up this project in github
and I'm going to kind of go back in time
to a previous commit before I did all
this
and we're just going to check out since
I have the resources page up let's just
check the resources page just to see
what the difference is so I'm going to
go and we'll put these side-by-side make
this a bit bigger for you and see I
haven't I actually haven't compared this
yet so hopefully it's the comparison is
somewhat obvious we might have to try
another file but you can see well aside
from you know slight slight difference
up here we have yes so I probably went
back too far some of the stuff had been
changed so let's get down more into the
into the body of this one of this even
going to be a good example no it's not
because I went back too far
sorry about that let me go back to a
commit that's maybe
let me go somewhere that's maybe right
there we go this this should be closer
oops click the wrong thing there we go
and sorry if you're if you're not
familiar with git and github and you're
just you know kind of watching this
you're probably somewhat confused about
how that works so sorry about that if
you watch some of the previous videos I
explained how more about how how it
works no my um my trackpad just ran out
of batteries so this is terrible at
least ight now would be a great time for
me to look back at the live chat and see
if I can get I do have a mouse here I'm
going to turn this mouse on so that I
don't have to actually leave and go get
batteries somewhere well though I could
change the batteries out from the mouse
and put them in the trackpad but there
we go it's just easier to use the mouse
alright I haven't used a mouse and so
long anybody I think if you use like a
MacBook or an iMac with the trackpad you
understand what I'm talking about once
you get used to it it's just like a
mouse using a mouse feels weird alright
so I do have a mouse now let's go I'm
actually going to go to that app dot J s
file because I think that has the most
potential for improvement and probably
the out of any of the the things that
I've done so that might be the most
drastic and obvious change so let me
[Music]
make us a little bigger and so we can
see so these are the same files before
and after using using prettier so we did
we did linting with standard J s and
then prettier does like the Auto
reformatting so let's see so far not not
not bad you saw I did take this out
because obviously like this is not
really needed if we're doing going to do
all of this linting and I'm actually
somewhat surprised at how well formatted
this was okay big here's the big thing
that that you can you probably already
even caught this there are no semicolons
at the end of the line here but there
are here and we talked about this
yesterday is that when when I was
learning JavaScript it was always like
you have to use a semicolon at the end
of the line right I mean I think some of
like the tutorials like the in browser
tutorials if you don't put the semicolon
it doesn't work you know you have to go
back and fix it so I'm trying to get
away from that but obviously I'm still
doing it I probably don't even realize
I'm doing it sometimes so with standard
J s you don't use semicolons and so all
the semicolons are gone
and all of it and everything still works
right it's not
nothing's crashed so that is an obvious
thing here we go this looks different
function sticking of okay so this is a
big example of a change right this is
really obvious so before we have I
actually didn't write this code you can
see I got this from someone on code pen
and credited in everything so it's it's
legit to use but everything was written
all in one line like
that which is pretty hard to read now
this is automatically done that it's all
moved on to separate lines so yes it
takes up more lines certainly but it's
so much easier to read like that so that
is one really useful kind of change in
the in the code there the other thing it
did was it made me so through an error
over this and it made me I was actually
had to change this I had to change this
manually it wouldn't let me just use
there and define all these things I had
to use a separate there for each line so
that's good to know
that that's that's the default with
standard jazz so you get the point you
can check out you you have access to the
repo you can check all this out so I
just wanted to show a quick example of
how this this works now I will check out
the live chat I'm sorry for having
ignored you but if you ever watch this
you know I am and once I look at the
live chat I tend to just talk a lot and
to you all and answer questions so I
wanted to make sure I got through this
and Wow okay so we pretty much got
through most of what I wanted to say in
less than half an hour so we'll say this
if you are only here to check out
prettier and standard Jas and you don't
really care for any of the
question-and-answer stuff you can thanks
for watching and you don't have to watch
anymore because that was the demo for
all of that but if you do have any
questions you want to stick around put
them in the live chat
I'll go through all the questions in the
live chat and I'll provide answers and a
lot of times everybody else in the last
chat provides really great answers as
well so it's a good resource to you if
you can't stick around or you're just
nervous about asking
question in the live chat you can direct
message me on Twitter or you can put it
in the comments to this video so a link
to my Twitter profile is in the
description for the video so let's get
to the Chad I'm starting at the top and
I'm just working my way down also let me
know I was getting some messages that
the stream health wasn't good so let me
know if you you had any problems with
this stream that's really odd usually
the internet connection that I have at
work is is really really fast okay so
everybody everybody if you remember the
beginning was kind of shouting out where
they're from which is awesome I love to
see where y'all are from so at Romania
Germany number one from Germany um
somebody asks about my editor which
which is great I don't mind me I get
asked that almost every video but I
don't really mind because you might just
join in you didn't weren't able to check
it out I do have a link in the
description to the the tools some of the
tools that I use so if you're interested
in what I use check out the description
I link pretty much everything that I'm
using I'm linking in there I've got
somebody else from Los Angeles let's see
I had said earlier I talked about I
asked if anyone else forgot to eat when
they were working and Patrick says for
kid to eat more than I remember de Rohan
forgets sometimes I forget that I've
eaten don't even know how that happens
so like somewhat of the opposite problem
okay so
Saurav has a question and this this
question was like maybe 20 minutes ago
so hopefully you're still here if not
maybe somebody else had still wants to
hear the answer ask how is this
different from es lint
okay so Vinay actually gave an
sir but I'll read it out in case you're
watching this video later on and can't
see the live chat and the answers as I
mentioned standard J s uses es lint as
vanassa's under the hood so kind of in
the background it's using es lint okay
so but it's using the the standard
illegal what is specified in standard J
s so you know if you go here and you can
read about the javascript standard style
okay so basically it's it's using es
lint to enforce the javascript standard
style and you don't have to do any of
the formatting but you don't have to
configure so I you don't have to
configure es lint at all it does it for
you sorry I'm going to take a drink okay
so hopefully that answers your question
and if not you know ask for
clarification and we can talk more about
it
Andrew says hello folks will watch the
replay on way to home have fun all right
thanks for stopping in Andrew yeah
throat you have any questions or
anything later on when you watch it put
it in the comments please
all right so Sebastian asks why don't
you use a linter for atoms so you get
the errors as you write them actually to
be honest with you I have up on my other
screen a couple of atom plugins that
were recommended from the the page the
page for standard jazz so I was looking
into using plugins for Adam to do just
that I just didn't have time to get it
all working before the video so if
anyone uses standard J s and uses Adam
and has a plugin that you want to
recommend please let me know and because
I like I was trying to read through some
plugins to figure out which one was the
best to use but I didn't come to any
conclusion yet
all right we have someone from Dubai
awesome
nobody says nice anyway I'm still
learning basic JavaScript and HTML this
stream is way above my knowledge we'll
come back to it in a few months when I
know a little more so note it yet not
every stream that I do is this high
level so some of them are really like
basic CSS changes or basic JavaScript
HTML stuff so just check out if you want
like you can follow me on Twitter and or
subscribe to the free code camp channel
and then you'll get alerts saying what
topic I'm going to be working on each
day and maybe there will be a topic
that'll be more like at your level where
you're at right now I'm also going to be
doing some beginner videos and putting
them on my own YouTube channel which is
linked in the description so you can
check that out as well
maybe if you want to subscribe it you
don't have to subscribe to my channel
but you'll get the benefit of being
alerted when I do upload those I think
since I'll be on vacation that next week
I'm going to be at the beach but it's
looking like there's going to be some
rain so maybe I'll try to get some of
those videos done then and so maybe
they'll be posted next week I think that
would be nice since I might not be able
to live stream if the Internet's down at
least maybe your fear Internet's not
good enough at least maybe I can upload
some of those pre-recorded videos and
those are going to be initially aimed at
like people who are just beginning
alright aim high says no to you we'll
get there I used to be in your shoes
eight months ago now I'm interviewing
for four companies awesome aim high
congratulations on that that's that's
really really awesome to hear let let me
know let us know if you get if you get a
job from any of the companies I'd love
to hear the good news so good luck with
that
someone from Orlando sends their
greetings hello from Nigeria awesome
andrew says if you get into industry and
you're good it escalates quickly so good
advice yeah just you know get in there
and give it a shot aim high says it yeah
mainly free code camp but supplement my
learning with udemy okay so awesome
resources obviously free code camp
because if you're here you know about
free code camp but udemy also a ten
dollar course I have done I did of
course from udemy before that was like
one of those ten dollar courses and I
did like it was useful I know if you've
if you've heard me before say I don't
think I've spent more than like thirty
dollars on courses learning this stuff
but you Demi was one of the places that
I did spend money on and I was I was
happy with with the course nobody says
learning with treehouse treehouse is
nice I've looked at treehouses stuff and
and it looked nice I haven't done that
much with it but maybe if anyone
watching has some experience with
treehouse - and wants to comment about
it from what I understand it seems like
it's a pretty good resource we have
someone from Russia
awesome
so lol lol asks hey Jessie how big is
your company how many employees we have
like 500 employees I think so I work at
a university a university here in the
United States and it's a small
university so we don't have maybe like
two thousand students so that's that's
considered a pretty small university and
we have I think about 500 employees and
that that includes the professor's as
well so the staff and the faculty
combined are about about 500 and my
particular I will actually work in the
marketing department and we have in my
entire department I think it's only
about 15 people and my my division
within my department there's only three
of us and only two of us actually do any
code so so it's really kind of small I
guess that we really only have two
people doing code and we almost never
even work on the same project because
we're just kind of really swamped with
projects all the time so I'm usually
working by myself as I mentioned earlier
I am getting some student workers and
maybe I'm trying to set up some
internship stuff to maybe for the Fall
so hopefully I'll have some more people
working I would really love that the
student workers involved so they can get
some good experience in using you know
github and some more modern build tools
and things and get some good experience
to put on their portfolio I think that
would be awesome so anyway I guess
that's you know kind of small
smoke of a small university we have
hello from India awesome
nobody says what I can stay away from
using semicolon and Jas yeah who knew
right
I only recently found that out I guess
I'm behind the game notes which is I
mean that happens if you you stay off
Twitter for a while it's easy to fall
behind aim high says um well says nobody
follow me on on code pen just go to code
plan and search my username so I don't I
don't know if aim high meant for me to
give the user name out loud so I'm not
so I'll just leave it out if you want if
you don't mind and you want me to read
out your username so people can check
out your code then let me know and I
will do it
Rowan prefers the semicolon and lol lol
also prefers so okay so we have some
some debate here about the semicolon I
prefer the semicolon simply because I'm
familiar with it I'm used to using it
but I imagine it will be better if I
just get rid of the semicolon that way
it's just one less thing I have to worry
about one last thing I have to do I'm
sure it will speed up my my coding ever
so slightly but over the long term
that'll probably add up and it will save
me like ten minutes of time which which
would be important I guess
Patrick says I really prefer 1 ver let
or Const with commas is their way
disabled that
yeah actually so if you're not sure what
he's referring to we had this comparison
here or was it
okay here so we when we use prettier or
I'm sorry when we use a standard js2
lint this it said that I had to change
this from using this there and just
using one Bayer and defining multiple
variables to putting each variable being
defined with its own ver on a separate
line there and Patrick asked if that can
be disabled I'm pretty sure it can this
anything that you can do in ES lint in
terms of disabling or customizing you
can do with standard je s because it's
using es lint in the background and if
worse comes to worse you could just add
in like a in a comment tag disable es
lint if you wanted to just disable that
portion that's that's kind of like would
be a pain to have to do that all the
time but if you really wanted to that
would work
andrew says Jessie have any experience
with browser extension so you mean like
making a browser extension if you mean
making a browser extension then no I've
never actually made my own browser
extension I have been interested in
doing it at times in the past but I just
never really like had had the time or
like a real need to do it but also at
least for my purposes if I wanted to
make a browser extension I can do
something it's easier for me to use
something like tampermonkey which i do
use and then just write the code in
tampermonkey and apply it so i kind of
get around having to really learn how to
make a browser extension and i can still
get done what I want to get done so
but otherwise I don't have any direct
experience with making a browser
extension alright listen one from
Palestine welcome and sorry it keeps for
some reason normally it doesn't do this
but today in the live chat I don't know
why but I keep getting bounced down to
the bottom of the chat so I keep losing
my place alright so okay Palestine
someone from Moldova Oh Andrew from
Moldova awesome I have my my wife has
some nieces and nephews and actually one
of them is my goddaughter who were
adopted from Moldova so awesome Nigeria
welcome daftar Pass are you done
yeah actually so I know it's it's real
which way early right it's I've only
been on for 40 minutes so and at the
time when you asked that it was I'd only
been on for half an hour so yeah
basically with for the topic of the
stream I'm done with that so I know we
had talked about doing shorter streams
so I'm making an effort to do shorter
streams if you if you missed if you're
just coming in and you missed it the
replay will be available on free code
camp just a few minutes after I end the
stream so you can watch the replay
andrew says today I made some big
rebates and merges had to remove some
big files from entire repository history
386 commits wow that's crazy yesterday
we did a stream on doing merges of pool
requests and stuff so wow that seems
like I mean I don't know maybe I don't
know what to compare that to but that
really seems like a lot of of commits to
be working with her
Yee dong asks where do you deploy the
website AWS it's actually digitalocean
all right ro unanswered that so yeah
digitalocean we do here at the
university we have three different hosts
right well actually four different hosts
the main website which is Franciscan ddu
is actually hosted here on campus and
the IT department runs their own
physical servers there okay that is
actually going to change soon and we're
gonna when we redesign the site which
will be like probably the next really
major project that I do I'll do a lot of
little projects in between when I start
that one but we have us out there we
host some sites on GoDaddy so we just
have like a little shared hosting
account that we just do some really
minor stuff with but it's easy to it's
nice to have because you can do like the
one-click five-minute WordPress install
and have something going and so we also
host on digital ocean and we have a site
on AWS all right we have someone from
Mexico awesome
all right nobody said thanks Jessie
you're welcome all right looks like
someone who's talking about getting
discounts on udemy courses and mob in 92
says you can go to real discount I've
never been there so I'm not endorsing
this site because I don't I don't know
what's on there but I guess there's
discounts for stuff on there I'm not
sure how to pronounce most of this name
but it ends with Isaac and I know how to
pronounce Isaac so I'm sorry I just
didn't want to mess up your name so
didn't want to attempt it but says which
would you advise becoming a full-stack
developer or front-end developer I one
day I would like to know enough about
the backend to be able to say I'm full
stack right now I'm only comfortable
saying that that I'm front-end and my
idea was well I'll start with front-end
and make money with that and then slowly
work my way to learn everything learn
the backend be full stack so that was my
idea and that's how I wanted to do it I
will say if you start from the outset
saying I want to be full stack you'll
probably get there sooner for me I just
had a family you know I need to take
care of and I need to pay the bills so
it was like okay I'm going to start out
because I know I can get money doing
front-end work right now
so I haven't made it to full stack as
quickly as I had hoped
just because I'm busy you know doing my
job is doing front-end stuff so it kind
of depends on what you want it a def
it's easier to become a front-end
developer than a full stack it'll take
less time so if you really need to kind
of get into it and start making money
with it go front-end first and then
learn the rest but if you have the time
to just dedicate to learning a go full
stack and then you'll make more money as
a full stack developer most likely
anyway so that's my advice maybe you all
watch that have some better advice than
that or some alternate opinions but
that's that's kind of my viewpoint on it
okay someone from Wales awesome hello
haha Andrew says with time you will be
full-stack even if you don't want it and
that's AG this kind of true I'm sure
Indra was joking a little bit but that
that is actually kind of true if you'll
see like if you've watched any of my
streams before occasionally I'm doing
stuff that's definitely not front-end
even though I'm a front-end developer
and especially if you're on a small team
or freelancing yeah you're gonna have to
learn a lot of stuff eventually so yeah
I mean probably most of us even if we're
doing mostly front-end stuff
occasionally do have to do back-end
stuff from time to time so it wouldn't
be that much of a jump for us to just do
some more learning and jump in and be
doing full-stack not to say that it's
easy to be full stack but just to say
that that's a natural progression
alright have someone from Brazil awesome
hello Andrew says semicolons are noise
for me
alright so Andrew Andrew is against
semicolons and we have what Rohan and
Patrick are on Team semicolon Roland
says you could do back-end exclusively
or networking or full stack it's just
what you like yeah I didn't even mention
that yeah I guess it depends on what you
like doing if you don't like going back
and stuff and don't try to be full stack
if you just like front-end stick with
that because that's important uh you
know you don't want to be stuck on
something that you don't like Rohan says
for example I get bored easily with one
thing so I would prefer full stack
Andrew says or what the company has for
you to work yeah that's that's important
to you know if you get a job doing one
or the other then that's that's what
you're going to do Rowland said with
small to medium companies you are
usually you usually are overworked but
you do get to try lots of stuff yeah
I can understand that Ross that's that's
where I'm at right now exactly small
company overworked but I do get to do a
lot of stuff so I will so this normally
my schedule is nice I don't work a lot
it's just been crazy for the last month
or so so hopefully I can get back to my
normal working hours and it won't be so
crazy
all right Sebastian says I'm Romanian
but for the past 89 years have been
living in Spain awesome
Andrew Andrew said he had a year in a
company and during that year tried Java
Scala PHP as a back-end language and
even wrote sequel so definitely a lot of
stuff just to do in one year okay the es
lint rule for repetitive there is one
one there so if you're interested in
learning how to get around this being
able to do this instead of being forced
to do this with the eslint the rule is
one very so you could disable one there
right or or enable unless I forget how
that works but basically look up in the
docs you know do a control fine for one
bear that's what you want what you want
to look for Rowan Rowan's commenting on
the length of the video when I was
talking about that that we went from
like two point seven hours to 30 minutes
big difference so definitely cut it on
this video is going to end up being an
hour after we get through the QA but the
actual like I want to say I'm not that I
didn't need coding today but would
normally be the coding portion was only
25 minutes which may be a record I think
in my early streams I kept it pretty
short but that's definitely short
compared to what we've been doing
Joshua asked what UI library do you like
to use with react I've been having
trouble with the app bar and material UI
so for this project I actually use
material
just the regular framework and I've had
to adapt things to react at times so I
don't know that I recommend doing
normally I do recommend materialise I
really like that framework I've used it
a lot and I'm familiar with their all
their conventions of like class names
and things so it's easy for me to build
things rapidly with materialize but I am
going to need to switch now that most of
what I'm doing is in react I think I'm
going to need to switch to something
that is more react specific so I know
there is someone linked I can't remember
maybe it was been a maybe yesterday
linked up to a set of react components
that were based on the materialized
framework so I'm have to check those out
I know there's material UI there's
material MD or no is it react MD I think
I still I must have closed the tab but
there was a another material design
style react framework that's out there
as well and it was MD something so I
don't I don't have a react like
component library to recommend to you
but I mean I have used materialized with
react and it's basically worked without
without too many issues even though it's
not really made for react components
andrew has some good advice when for
when we're talking about commits and
everything get commits since when you
remove something from entire repository
history every commit changes hashes so
you have to be careful when announced
too old team members yeah
definitely keep that in mind when you're
trying to decide like which how you're
going to merge things and if you're
making changes to your commits but how
is that going to affect your other team
if it's just you then you can pretty
much do whatever you want I guess and it
won't really matter but if you have a
team of people submitting pool requests
and all working on a project then you
don't want to mess everything up for
them so decide on beforehand I guess on
how you're going to handle things like
that with your team
Vinay asks did you check now dot essays
for hosting actually I went to a
conference where they demonstrated how
to use now to get a site up and running
and you can even buy domain names right
through the command line it was really
awesome and quick so I am familiar with
using that I think I think I would like
to use it at some point I mean obviously
not for this project we already have
everything set up but possibly for some
smaller projects I would like to do that
I'm not sure like I mean obviously we're
doing some load balancing and we have
this running on multiple servers and
then there's so there's a lot more going
on here but I think there will be some
smaller sites that I'll be working on in
the near future I think that would be a
good candidate for trying that out I'll
have to look into the pricing as well
because obviously I would want to use if
I'm doing this officially for my job
we're going to be using a you know a
custom domain and I think if you use
your own domain at that point you have
to be using I don't remember the pricing
structure but anyway often check the
only thing basically I need to look into
is the pricing and see if it would make
sense to do it like that but otherwise
I'm very impressed with using now for
hosting so if you're not familiar with
that the same people that do
next J s which is the basically kind of
I don't know what the right term for it
is but like the scaffolding for that I'm
using to build with react that same the
same people do now which is a way of
very easily deploy straight from the
command line right to hosting and it's
it's just it's so simple you know
definitely check it out I don't want to
spend a lot of time describing what I
saw at this conference because you could
probably just find the video a video of
it or check it out for yourself and see
but I mean literally as I mentioned you
you can do as much as even buy a domain
name right from the command line and in
a few commands have a completely new
website up and running with your own
custom domain and an SSL and all that it
really really kind of slick and a nice
process
[Music]
nobody says lol Jesse I'm following the
same footsteps I'm focusing on front-end
then later on back-end but I want to get
my foot in with front-end yeah I mean I
don't think it's a bad like I said it
depends on what you need you know point
in life here and what you need I mean
for me it's just like I didn't have time
to just spend a lot of time studying and
and dedicate my time to that I needed to
make money like literally I had quit a
job and I was looking for work and
couldn't find work and I needed to make
money and learn something so I caught a
break and a friend of mine had a
marketing company that needed some
website work someone to do website work
and you know I was getting some work on
the side with them and the only way for
me to get even more work was to learn
this stuff so that was what just what I
needed to do because I had a family I
had to pay bills so if I had to do it
again maybe I would have and I was
completely single with not a lot of
responsibilities maybe I would have
tried to like just dedicate a bunch of
time to just learning and be you know be
full-stack but
either way I think is is definitely
respectable legitimate way of going it
just depends on what you need matt says
it pays to spend the time to really
learn one aspect first okay so awesome
yeah something to be said for focusing I
guess on focusing your attention on one
thing
sebastian asks where should I start
looking for work as a front-end dev and
we have some answers in the live chat
I'll read em out Rohan says oh this
isn't an answer that question and rusev
Stack Overflow so yeah definitely Stack
Overflow has this whole job board that's
that's really awesome so let me bring
this up just in case I'm sure most of
you are familiar with Stack Overflow but
if you haven't seen the jobs yet there
you see the jobs right here right and
they they will show you jobs based on
what you searched for on Stack Overflow
like assuming you have an account and
everything in and they have your data
and usually like there are awesome jobs
like you know check this out front-end
developer 90 to 130 Kay that's insane
that's that's a lot of money
way more than I make so you know if you
check it out you get lots of details
about the job right there you know so I
would just check it out check out there
and then it's as simple as this and you
get a lot of other related jobs I've
been really impressed with Stack
Overflow we're actually advertising a
position here at this university for a
web developer on Stack Overflow right
now and I was really the one who pushed
for like we need to list on Stack
Overflow because I was so impressed with
how they do things and and how they
suggest jobs to to people I thought that
was kind of really really like no other
site has has that kind of data and that
user base to be able to do with Stack
Overflow jobs does so if you're looking
to get like a full-time job definitely
do that if you want to just find
freelance work then networking with
people directly I found to be
way better than going on one of the
freelance job sites the jobs I got from
those sites were usually not very
high-paying and they didn't they didn't
amount to much like I didn't get like
repeat clients or a lot of good leads
from there that was just my experience
the better clients were personal
connections and I would have a client
that they were really impressed with
what I did and then they recommended me
to other people they knew and then it
just kind of grew my like freelance
business grew naturally like that so it
takes a little while but those clients
were were repeat clients and they were
great to work with so that I had a
better experience with that
we had some there's some discussion more
about whether to go full sack or front
end first row on prefers networking in
back-end but hasn't really had a real
job yet so don't doesn't really know for
sure Matt says better to focus in one
direction or or the other and that leads
to deeper understanding in one spot yeah
definitely I mean if you force yourself
to focus you're going to be way better
that one thing than you ever would have
if you didn't there's a quote from
somebody I've no idea who was but I read
a book before and they were saying that
to be great at something you have to say
no to everything else right so you have
to focus on that one thing if you want
to be as great as you possibly can at
that one thing even though you could be
great at lots of different things if you
would have choose to do those things you
have to focus on one if you want to be
really good so I definitely agree with
that
I mean I'm there's some really talented
people that are great full-stack
developers but even then if they would
have focused all their attention I think
on on one area they could have been even
better at that one area than they
already are
so but I mean you need you need people
of all you need some people that don't
want to focus and want to have a more
broad understanding so and there's there
are jobs for all different types of
people depending on what you want to do
if you want to focus or if you want to
be having more general knowledge of more
things
Zachary says it feels like the line
between front and back-end is so blurred
in the Jas world I agree this there's
definitely some blurring there I mean
because you're running JavaScript on
client side and server side so it feels
a lot of it does feel the same but when
I switch over like you know I'm doing
front-end stuff basically but you know I
have this this server Jas file like have
I now switched to the backend world just
with one click here like it's still all
the same thing I'm using cost I'm using
javascript like it it is it does feel
weird sometimes
um you know like where where is that
that line but but any I mean like I said
I think most of what I do is front end
so it's clear in my mind that I'm a
front-end developer even though I do
back-end stuff occasionally blazer Tron
all right so we're back to the semicolon
debate lasertron says learning the
basics of JS but I'd rather use
semicolons mainly because I've been told
that yeah I'm in the same boat that's I
I don't I'm probably going to try not to
use semicolons as much as possible and
certainly now that it's going to
automatically take them out for me I'm
not going to have them but yeah I've
always been told you semicolon so it is
kind of a weird thing
although learning to use reacts is the
same way cuz you've always been told
don't put your CSS in line and mix it
with with your HTML and then you become
to react and we have JavaScript HTML and
CSS all mixed together right it just
seems weird once you get used to it it's
actually really nice but it's hard at
first uh first it seems like the latch
at the is like a never-ending chat today
so which is great it looks like we have
some great discussion going on here so
I'm going to keep yeah I'd say probably
we can get through this in about ten
minutes so about ten minutes I'm going
to end so I can kind of get move on to
do some some other work that is probably
boring and I don't even want to put on a
live stream so if you got a question get
it in in about ten minutes if I can't
get all the questions then please put
them in the in the comments or direct
message me on Twitter and I will answer
them so person asks how long have you
been learning I've been learning for the
past year and it feels like I'm not
progressing anywhere I've been learning
this for a long time I first learned how
to build websites in 2003
somewhere around there and that was just
basic stuff we just opened up notepad on
on a PC and started doing basic HTML and
CSS and doing layout with tables and
things like that so but I I didn't
really do that much with it after that
so I would say I've only really been
like intensely trying to learn
JavaScript in particular for like maybe
the last four years five years I don't
even want to say five like maybe maybe
the last three or four years have I
really been focused on getting better at
JavaScript before that I was doing
websites but I was I wasn't like
intentionally saying I want to get
really good with JavaScript it was more
I was focusing more on CSS at that point
so I'd say three years of it more
intense focus to get where I'm at right
now
so don't don't be discouraged if it
feels like you're not progressing it
doesn't always go sometimes you learn a
lot really fast and you feel awesome and
then you work for a long time and it
feels like you're not getting anywhere
and then you'll hit another like spurt
like a growth spurt right remember when
when we were kids and you just like you
go to have summer break and you come
back to school and some people would be
like Giants and because they hit a gross
fare right the same thing happens in
coding that's probably a terrible
analogy but the same thing does happen
with coding like all of a sudden you
just like it seems like things are just
all making sense and you you just get
really good and and then you'll hit
another plateau you will have a point
where it doesn't seem like you're
progressing but just because it doesn't
seem like you're progressing like you
you are you're learning things you're
retaining things it just needs to fit
together
for you so if this is something you
really want to do and you enjoy doing
doing then stick with it don't get
discouraged I'm constantly looking back
at things that
even a few months ago and saying wow
like I I definitely would do it
differently now I've learned you know
I've gotten better so and you'll get
there you'll have a bunch of those
moments uh-huh
Patrick's going back to the semicolon
thing Patrick does not care about
semicolons in and of themselves but more
about consistency so if you're doing
simple dance with no tooling preventing
you from then use semicolons if so I
guess use whatever you're used to using
if you don't have tooling to make it
consistent for you so that seems to be
Patrick's point there which is a good
point person clarified the question a
little bit but I think I answered that
Matt Matt in response to person says it
starts slow but it can really pick up
find some projects doing something you
enjoy and it will pick up fast the more
you enjoy it the easier will be for you
to spend more time with your head in it
good advice Matt in person ask any
projects you recommend I'd love to work
on some so hmm I don't I don't know what
your level is out in terms of projects I
know there are some websites that just
have project ideas I don't remember what
the addresses are for those sites now
but I'm sure if you kind of search for
that concept you'll find some you could
also try you know some of the like
coding tutorials have projects you could
work on like free code camp if you
haven't gone through free code camp
stuff there are a lot of projects in you
don't have to go through everything to
get there first you could just pick one
out and try it if you want just to get
an idea or you can sometimes I just ask
people like friends and family like hey
if do you have any good ideas for
websites or apps or anything like that
and see if there's a good idea that they
have that you could work on especially
if they're not coders then they're
obviously never going to do that they're
never going to use their ideas so that
they'd probably be really happy
you tried to make their idea really
happen nobody says a Jessie I just
installed standard and the bracket
brackets extension is that it okay so I
I'm alright so I don't use brackets so
I'm just assuming that it's similar
enough to add them that this would work
so you'll need to if you're using the
extension then that should give you the
warnings right there so yeah that should
work you should as long as you're seeing
the the warnings about syntax in in your
editor then you're good to go
it may not work exactly like mine's
working where it like automatically
checks everything as soon as I get a do
a commit
so that part you might need to set up
differently but if you just want like
the linting in editor then you should be
good to go somebody who maybe uses
brackets might be able if you're in the
live chat now maybe you'll be able to
give some better more specific advice
all right andrew has good advice kind of
along the lines with what I was saying
my experience was was check your code
from one year ago and if you feel it
needs improvement then then you've grown
that's great about yet if you look at
code you did from an earlier time and
you notice things like oh I should have
done this differently or I can correct
that then you know you've learned you
know you've improved because obviously
when you wrote it you didn't know enough
to make it the right way like it should
have been so great advice matt says
about two years ago I went on a family
vacation to Alaska and to share pictures
I set up a website to upload and display
photos videos think like private
Facebook yeah that's a really good idea
so that that's a good idea of a project
to do you know if you're interested in
something like that
thanks to that I really liked that idea
I might Matt I might do that that might
be a legit idea for me to work on on
vacation and not have everybody be mad
at me for working on vacation because
I'm actually doing something that will
contribute to the vacation so that's
good I I'm going to share a little
personal thing right here I hope you
don't mind but my wife's one on vacation
with all my wife side of the family so
her brothers and their wives and their
kids and my mother and father-in-law and
some of her aunts and and and her uncle
so all her side of family they're very
creative and like musically talented so
there's always like these times are like
okay we're going to have like a talent
night like everybody write a story and
we're going to read it out to them or
we're gonna we're gonna play songs or
music and I have no musical ability at
all I really like music I like to listen
to music but I I can't make music I'm
not a good singer like nothing and when
I hear like I got an email saying we're
gonna do like a contest about writing a
story on vacation and I get like anxiety
over that like I don't really want to
write this story and to me
I'm like can I just make a website with
that work because that makes me excited
but the other stuff makes me have
anxiety so the reason why I share that
was I'm thinking maybe instead of me
contributing with some musical thing or
a story my contribution could be some
very useful website that can capture
that family vacation and everybody can
go to it and remember it so so Matt
thanks for that idea because I might
actually do that we'll see I don't want
to work all the vacation I really do
want to hang out with my family and then
my kids but it would be nice to just
code a little bit I don't know I just
feel if I go for a long time without
coding I feel weird like I miss it does
anybody else ever get that feeling on
the negative side I I think like maybe
I'm addicted to coding and this is a
problem on the positive side I think hey
I do I found something that I really
love to do so it could go one way or
another out depending on how you want to
look at it but but I'm interested to see
if anybody else feels like that let me
know I suspect somebody else has to feel
like that I can't be I can't be the only
one and if I am then maybe I do need to
get some professional help need to need
to talk to a counselor or something Matt
says in in regard to that site that
Facebook like site he worked with PHP
HTML CSS and JavaScript and getting
ready to rewrite it in Django so he says
in my current role I am a DBA leading up
a Django project to rewrite our main
application awesome all right so Rohan
says improvement if I see code from 7 to
10 months ago I feel like killing
someone until I realized this was me
that's great
I love that that sentiment right so I
cringe when I look at a
old code occasionally I'm pleasantly
surprised and I'm like oh this isn't as
bad as I thought it would be but
something usually I'm like I don't even
want to look at it I just like alright
this site still works like I'm just
gonna let it go I don't I don't want to
revisit this person says that's awesome
I haven't had much inspiration and
Andrew I just checked my stuff from a
year ago you're right there was
definitely improvements Thanks all right
I'm glad that that we could help I
definitely want this live chat in the
community that's starting to develop
around it to be a very like positive
uplifting community especially for
people who are new I think that that's
there's a lot of good tutorials and
resources for new people and I want it
to be like that but I think more
importantly this could be a place of
inspiration and encouragement for people
that are just starting and for this you
know they've been doing it for a little
longer and maybe just kind of getting a
little bit down about things so that's
something that I think you can't get
from just reading a tutorial not necess
you know you can't necessarily get that
but in a more like active living
community like this we can help each
other out in that way and at least for
me that's that's if that happens if
that's what this ends up being this
dream and all of you that watch and
contribute if it ends up being a place
that encourages people to learn how to
code and continue in it then I'll be
happy and I'll be I'll be happy that I
did sacrifice some of the time in the
effort to do this
Daffy dev says what's a good resource
for react convention within a large
project I'm always confused on how much
I should put into a single component I'm
sure that you probably get an answer
somewhere but in the live chat for this
dafter but I would say your components
should be like as small as possible they
should be only like one thing and you
may end up with a ton of components
it's been my understanding that the
correct way to do things in react is
that like if something can reasonably be
broken down into a smaller component
then do it and then that keeps them it
keeps them small it keeps them easy to
understand and more modular so that you
can reuse them so does that make sense
let me know if I need to explain that
more if I didn't make sense or if any of
you disagree with that viewpoint but
that's that's my understanding of
ideally how it should work when you're
using react let's see I'm looking we're
getting bad yeah we've hit definitely
hit that 10 minutes of where I said I
wanted to end so I'm just going to look
see if there's any like really important
questions I want to get to especially
from somebody who's new or maybe just
learning because I definitely want to
not that I don't appreciate all of you
that are more experienced and and are in
the lab chat a lot but I know you won't
be offended if I don't get your question
I don't want to I don't want to offend
somebody if this is their first time
asking a question and they get ignored
so let's see so cactus asks what about
markup developer what if you don't want
to create markups but you have to do
this run in dev all support like
mock-ups so you talk about design work
right so cactus correct me if I'm wrong
but I think you're talking about design
work like what if you have to do design
work is the front-end dev but you don't
want to well I would say either if you
can talk to your your boss about it and
see if maybe you can get a real designer
contract that out or something then do
it otherwise I mean maybe look for
another another job I do have to do
design work even though I'm a front-end
developer I don't always like doing the
design work especially the beginning of
a project when it's like a blank slate
I'm always that's the worst part for me
because I could I could make it look
like anything you know so it's just hard
to make a decision but I would imagine I
mean how many people watching our front
end of
ella purrs and also have to do design
work I know I do for sure I imagine that
somewhat common depending on you know
how big a company you work for so but if
you definitely don't want to be doing
that then I would recommend you try to
find a different job or try to bring
that up you know in your team and see if
something else could be done you know
you may have to keep doing it for a
while until you can find something
better but I mean I totally I'm in the
same situation so I definitely
understand that let's see
I'm just looking for questions right now
usually I do read everything out and you
all know that if you've seen it before
so but since this is going on pretty
long that's why I'm skipping a little
bit aim high asks hi Jesse so all what
you are doing is cashing on the server
side all your routing is on the front
end kind of so yeah basically the once
the page loads so I did I have had the
server up here for a while
so what happens is next Jas has I'll go
here and show you so in get initial
props this fetch of the data happens on
the server side so the initial page load
and everything it all gets rendered
server-side and just the HTML you know
is pushed out for search engine purposes
that's that's good but once the page
loads and you click on an internal link
then you get no page refresh it's it is
it's all client-side routing and the the
API calls that would normally be here
and run on the server now can run on the
client as well but I am doing a lot of
caching so potentially those calls don't
even get made if they don't need to so
you can see like in the server like I'm
cashing it for an hour
um not in when I'm development I don't
catch it for an hour but so it's caching
the rendered HTML where the API call has
already been made on the server they've
gotten that data rendered all HTML
that's cached so you can get like a
really quick response from the server
because it only has to go to the node
server to go right back it doesn't
actually have to ask WordPress for
anything because it's already cached
that so that's what I'm doing there and
then it does switch over so if you go to
the site catechetical comm and check out
the routing
oh man it's so we're switching my mouse
I'm not on my trackpad now it's really
weird to try to find all my windows but
basically yeah if you try to route and
you'll notice there is no page refresh
so it's a combination of server-side and
client-side rendering routing good
question though let me know if you have
any other questions uh put it in the
comments or direct message me on Twitter
if you if you want to like talk about it
in more depth it's like how how and why
I did it
Rohan says I'm addicted to got to do
something aim high I feel you Jesse okay
I'm not the only one
rollin says it is saying predict in
particular person but every in this goes
for everybody that's that's watching now
live or later on if you want us to help
outside of here you can drop by in our
IRC anytime so we do have an IRC channel
for this for this stream and it's
hashtag FCC Jesse so hashtag FCC Jes s
so you can join that I'm in there like
occasionally I do I am linked up on my
phone so a lot of times I I do get the
the messages that come through so but I
try to pop in you know a couple times a
day and there are other people that are
in there too so if you need help with
something you know come in there and ask
some questions or if you're more
advanced and you want to help some
people come in there and provide some of
your your experience
Rowen says apart from those Patrick
Jesse and a few other nobody here is
even in the neighborhood of awesome I
don't I don't think I should be put on
the list of awesome either but this is
we could definitely improve it I would
say the only thing awesome about me is
that for some reason I decided it would
be a good idea to show the world how
much of a noob I am every day
when I do coding I don't know that
everybody would be able to do that so
that's that maybe it's something unique
about it but really you all helped me so
much with with mice improving my skills
that I think I'm getting just as much if
not more out of this than you are Andrew
says no stop posting Jessie will not
finish this endless conversation thanks
Andrew
that is true yeah I just can't stand to
leave questions unanswered if you all
have questions you know maybe maybe you
really need that question answered it
can make a big difference in your life
so I just want to answer it but alright
but this will be it last question
Rohan asks what would be your next
project if you are allowed to reveal it
alright let me think what will the next
project be I don't know for sure how the
order is going to be so I'll tell you
maybe one or two that's possible there's
going to be potentially a site that
doesn't really have a name or you are or
anything yet but could possibly
aggregate content from all of our other
university sites into one place and pull
it all in if I do that site I'm going to
use the WordPress API because a lot of
our sites are running WordPress and I'm
going to pull it all and it's going to
be a react site it's going to be set up
similar to this but of course better
because what why do say site exactly
like you did the last one right you want
to improve so it'll be similar to this
if I do that it'll be cool because I'll
get to start right from scratch and show
the whole way which I know you know a
lot of people have been asking for that
to start from scratch so that's one
potential project that it's going to
happen like I'm like 90% sure what's
going to happen I'm just not sure when
the other project that I was working on
before this if you look on my youtube
channel I did a couple of live streams
where I was trying to do a redesign of
our main website Franciscan ddu but I
was trying to live
like within the restrictions of the
current content management system that
will get replaced so basically I was
trying to make that site look nice and
run as fast as possible within the
constraints that I have to work in so
that was kind of a weird situation but
made it interesting because I couldn't
use a lot of the tools and the
techniques that I would like to use
because of those constraints so those
two projects are for sure happening
there might be some little like one-page
sites that will pop in here and there
but that that's about as good of an
answer as I can give you right now and
shoot Andrew did ask one more question
and it's a follow-up to an earlier
question so I'm going to take it because
technically I don't think it's really
new just a clarification Andrews saying
so the server side also fetches data
from WordPress or is only HTML gets to
the front end and then fetches so this
is to clarify before from aim highest
question it actually does fetch the data
on the server so if you want to test it
out I'm not going to do it right now
because then I'll be here for another
ten minutes but go to the website on
your first load of the website so don't
do don't click any links on the first
load go to view source so don't use the
inspector view the source and it you
know to come up with a really ugly
looking white eight page of HTML you'll
be able to see all the data right there
right if it was fetching it client-side
you wouldn't see all the data you just
see the initial markup that gets loaded
all right but it's actually making the
API calls server-side first and then
sending it all all completed and
rendered out the way it should look that
way search engines see the complete page
otherwise search engine wouldn't see all
that data they were pulling from
WordPress so that's the main reason why
we do it I have I haven't tested it this
myself but I've heard other people say
that you get a slightly faster first
page load if you do it that way
as well so finally get into the end of
the live chat I did go kind of fast at
the end so if I missed your question I
sincerely apologize and please ask it in
the comments or message me on Twitter
and I will answer it as soon as I can
thank you to everybody for watching we
had a lot of action in the live chat a
lot of viewers I think above average for
most of the the stream we had above
average amount of years so thank you so
much for everything for all the input
you all had I'll be back tomorrow same
time 2 p.m. eastern time not sure what
the topic will be yet I'll pick it
tomorrow and thanks thanks to the two
people that submitted pool requests big
thanks to Venegas Rome shoot and I can't
find it because I don't have my trackpad
I think it was Daniel if it wasn't I'm
sorry but the two people is submitted
pool requests since yesterday I really
really appreciate that you did an
awesome job but I loved the requests and
it's definitely a big improvement in the
project so anyway thanks thanks for
watching and I'll be back tomorrow have
a great day